live I had a meeting and then just
completely zoned out for a half an hour
doing I don't know what Twitter and oh
no wait I wrote a reply to a
reviewer yeah okay I was doing something
productive
good uh let's switch this
to did I lose a Shadow Duel I'm freaking
disappearing
here uh hold
on freaking banished to the shadow real
let me
good I gotta say this thing right
here I'm very excited about
awesome this has got to be like some of
the
most I don't know which was the more
degenerate gaming this or RuneScape it's
kind of a toss
up I mean what's more degenerate like
freaking like sweating hard raids on day
one or like playing a game on six
different clients at the same time I
don't
know of course I get an actual like
legitimate comment while I'm doing
something silly welcome PhD was
inspiring thank you I've got uh I've got
another cool video coming out soon I've
got like 20 hours on of editing to do
but I think I've got all the footage now
unless I decide to re-record stuff I
think it'll be better than my thesis
defense I really do it's going to be a
lot more subjective it's a lot more
about like how puffer positioned in RL
and like all the problems that I see um
but I think people are going to I think
it's going to get people talking I think
it
will be out as soon as I can you know do
20 hours of
editing so um let's see here we just
figured
out some silly build things
right wasn't that bad bad
maybe and I guess now the uh the idea is
going to be to go look at
the
code and see what we can
do
uh let me look at the
stack I guess I'll just spend a little
time sort of thinking out loud
here um because I was trying to do
something cool with this so
right here we have a bajillion different
versions of
snake um and the first one that I built
is SE snake. pix
right so this is a scyon implementation
of snake it's 230
lines and then we
have in order for this to work there's
also snake. Pi which binds this it's 216
lines and it includes the renderer
450 lines or
so and then there
is
snake. which is 4117 lines but includes
both the render and neural network board
pass in raw
C this one's quite nice and in order to
make this work there's a little bit more
to it but I don't think it's that bad
there is Si snake pix 83 lines I think
i' i' like to figure out how to reduce
the size of this binding like there are
some weird redeclaration and stuff it's
basically a glorified header file which
is obnoxious considering I already have
one um but this gets all of your data
from python into C without having to do
weird like Pi object API
stuff uh and then there is SE snake. Pi
which is our wrapper here if I look at
render
RB client so I have to strip I think
what I got to do now is I have to strip
all the extra code out of this so we're
just
using the uh the
C and then I have to see how little code
we're left with
and then we'll go from there so we'll
basically be able to compare the python
scon code to the python C with a little
bit of scyon glue
code and we'll see how that
looks I'm not entirely sure
[Music]
um how I would do multiple different
files with different environments and
stuff I think environments have to have
their own file at the very least maybe
there'll be like a puffer li. C which is
like
shared
stuff we'll have to think about
that check
something
so reset
aen Seas
this let's say rib I think rib is the
mode right
uh I kind of did that guy so I got it to
compile I think and
run um but for whatever reason maybe you
know this issue
so when I use uh an extension like
capital E
extension it will take the compiled file
and it'll put it in the root of the
project but when I just inline a string
and just like put a single uh scon file
it'll build it alongside the original
source
file uh so
basically with the extension like you
have to import it from The Source you
can't maintain the same hierarchy and I
don't know why that
is maybe you know
nope check if yeah all right that's what
I figured I don't think it's syon it's
setup tools
and they surprisingly really don't have
that good of
documentation
I did you see the new M's people have
been posting in puffer they're pretty
awesome
this so it's
not it does actually expand it just
doesn't resize I
guess but uh this is the correct client
running in
C so we'll have to add some options to
this but that's really sweet isn't
it this runs in pure
C we'll have to figure out um a few
other of the render
modes use the restroom real quick I'll
be right
back and then I want to figure out how
small we can get this file to be
I think it could be pretty
easy we'll be right
have have you compiled with Dash
O's I think it's yeah the CI compiled I
think with some options sithon just adds
those though it's kind of weird it'll
just add a bunch of
decrease the binary
size oh- o s no I meant I thought you
meant - o like apostrophe s like it'll
do 01023
I'm trying to think what I want to
actually trim
here frankly pretty tough to do this at
this point
these these could all very easily be
ported to
um to see couldn't
they and then this thing would be very
thin that'd be kind of
okay so the render function right now
doesn't have the actions on
and it's actually if I think about it
it's better to not Port the
um it's better to really only have one
of the renderers in C which is going to
be like whichever one will be used for
web demos right
because the rest of them you want to be
able to just be Dro in with python just
like you have them
and like technically if I do like this
what happens
so if I
render this
is uh this is the RB
renderer in
Python which is pretty cool actually
this is like much better featured right
than the the
C1
interesting we'll have to reconsider a
little bit what code needs to live where
I am quite happy to have resolved the uh
compilation thing
though let me
see I'm trying to think if there's
anything else I want to do on this
tonight or if I'm kind of happy that
this works and I just want to like spend
a couple hours editing get some food and
go to bed
that might be the smarter thing to
do yeah cuz this basically at this point
this all works
and um it's just going to be like a
matter of me being fresh and uh slowly
refactoring things around until the
right code lives in C the right code
lives in Python uh and there's very
little structure like uh required
structure or redundancy or any of those
things um and then from there I think
it'll be pretty easy to apply stuff to
other areas uh the one other thing that
I have to do that maybe I should stream
because it would be a little more
interesting I need to figure out a way
to
handle multi-dimensional arrays in
C
um so technically you can make like um a
matrix class or not a class like a
matrix struct or like a tensor
struct and that can have uh with like
this that can have dimensions and then
you can have that thing be indexed
easily
enough it's a little awkward because I
think it's hard to handle multiple data
types so I'll have to do a bit of
research on how to handle
that um but I think that's about it
so yeah quiet evening anyways um I think
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
edit on the video for a couple hours
just so we see if I can make some
progress towards that uh and then I'll
see if I can stream a bit tomorrow uh
hopefully while I'm fresh I'll get a
little bit done on this maybe uh or on
one of the other M if viewers have stuff
to add there uh but really I just want
to get this video done this week so
it'll be behind me and uh we can start
like really getting back into Dev mode I
find it very hard to Contex switch
between like creative like social
Endeavors like a
presentation and code so I think while
I'm still uh mainly thinking about that
video I'm going to spend more time
getting that done and then hopefully
towards the end of the week it'll just
be shipped and uh you we'll be able to
get back to this stuff so thanks
everyone for tuning in uh and I will be
back tomorrow